beck's kitchen is a single mom who works
three jobs all paying the living wage
she gets just over 400 pounds a week for
herself and her young son to live on out
of that she pays for rent bills food and
anything else they need she welcomes the
increase but says she'll still struggle
i'm kind of into minds i'm partly
relieved because i think it's going up
more than it usually would but on the
other hand i'm also a bit frustrated
because it's not a magic wand and it
doesn't fix everything in terms of the
rising costs of really everything and
obviously the drop in universal credit
as well
the government calls the minimum wage
for those aged 23 and over the living
wage it will rise from 8 pounds 91 to 9
pounds 50 an hour that means a full-time
worker will earn more than a thousand
pounds extra a year before tax
for people aged 21 to 22 the minimum
wage will go up from 8 pounds 36 to 9
pounds 18. the rate for apprentices will
go from 4 pounds 30 to 4 pounds 81 an
hour
low wage earners will take home more
from next april but the cost of living
is already rising with everything from
petrol to energy prices soaring
motorists are having to dig deeper than
ever with petrol hitting one pound 42 a
litre i think we're getting ripped off
that's all i could say
um
it's got what 20p later in in about
three or four weeks
makes no makes no sense yeah i'm very
worried that
usually we work a mini cup
is very higher and they affect me a lot
but the government says the living wage
increase will help compensate for the
recent withdrawal of the 20 pounds
universal credit uplift payment
we're confident this is a really big
step to make sure that work always pays
which is obviously one of the core
objectives of this government and this
pay rise has been recommended by the low
pay commission they're an expert group
they bring together academics as well as
businesses and crucially we are
confident that they have the right
evidence base and experience to make
judgments about what is required to make
sure that work does pay
but those facing higher wage bills like
restaurant owner jordan hallows say
businesses are struggling after the
pandemic
he has four restaurants and employs more
than a hundred staff twenty percent are
on minimum wage and i believe in our
industry that the majority of operators
want to pay their staff as much as they
possibly can but ultimately it comes
down to the price of a glass of wine or
food on the plate so it will probably
mean for us absorbing it in the first
instance and then having to increase the
prices of the items on our menu
labour wants the living wage to be 10
pounds an hour critics say the
government's pledge won't come quickly
enough for those already worried about
surviving the winter lisa holland sky
news